hi I'm welcome to episode number 52 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm here with
my dear colleague mark Mendel hey Mark
hey Francis how you doing today very
happy surrounded by lots of really cool
people here at we are in month of it
we're not in month of you were actually
in Sunnyvale yeah we're the gde summit
the Google developer experts summit is
taking place yeah it's been really
really cool we're hanging out with all
the Google developer experts they're all
excellent people and yeah very happiness
they're so interesting so many so many
cool interviews we're gonna have a bunch
of short interviews where they're
basically gonna be telling us about what
they do and they do really cool stuff
they do the really cool stuff and they
do a bunch of events all around the
world so it's well worth listening to
yeah and and then at the end we'll we'll
have a question of the week that comes
from slack apparently yeah it comes from
the slack community really cool question
about datastore yeah it involves it is
interesting because actually when I
heard the question I was like I'm
actually not sure about the answer and
then oh that makes sense
yeah but yeah so that will be at the end
but before we're gonna have we're
cooking of the week and today is
actually about a blog post yeah it's a
really cool blog post I really like it
the title is how to avoid a
self-inflicted DDoS attack CRE life's
lessons yeah don't like self-inflicted
harm it's just a bad thing the worst
part is that I've actually done the
things that they say do do not do this I
totally written code that did this yep
and I think I think it's one of these
articles where you read it and you're
like oh yeah that totally makes sense
but I'm until like somebody tells you to
do these things yeah why would that be a
thing yeah so I actually the one that
I'm and then a road was he's actually
the first one as I've done do that where
it says try exponential back-off so if
something fails so what it did was
actually worse well before you before
you go into that let's set some context
so the whole idea of the blog post the
whole idea of the blog post is
is not best practice is the worst
practices like what are the things that
if you ride like that they could create
issues right so it's oh like you should
not just send requests on a fixed
interval regardless of
service working or not because then at
the end basically what you're doing is
you are the more and more more services
trying to connect to your back end and
the back end is not up so when he comes
up you have a huge amount of traffic
waiting for it
yep so you said you should try
exponential back-off what I did was even
better I actually wrote on App Engine
app that whenever a good fell it gets in
the message to itself so yeah so very
being very funny to see how office lone
App Engine scales very well I was able
to send messages up to it saying I
failed yeah like there were more
messages that it was like to it so it
was awful yeah server architecture is
fun yeah yeah that is one of the things
try exponential back-off
it always hurt yeah it always helps yeah
no there there are several really great
things in here about if you're building
like particularly mobile apps with
services as a back-end that could go
down because yeah software fails so
techniques like exponential back-off
adding a little jitter implement retry
mocking things like that well worth your
time because it can save you a lot of
time if something goes horribly horribly
wrong and you need to get everything
back up again yeah it definitely
definitely helps avoid outages and
especially when an outage happens
minimize the effects of it so yeah
definitely check it out I think it's a
it's a great blog post I really enjoyed
it and now to start with the main
content for today we're gonna be talking
with alexis moussine
pushkin also known as alexis MP he's
gonna be telling us a little bit about
who are the gd's yeah and what they do
so we're here now with someone else from
our team
no developer advocate though but what
what are you who are you Alexei's could
you tell us a little bit real quick who
you are whether you do a Google sure I'm
Alexi mission pushkin I usually go by
Alexei MP and I look after a number of
communities that we have that is
developer communities and one of them is
Google developer experts gdes and
specifically the ones that are
specializing in cloud so for the episode
today we're actually interviewing a
bunch of them could you tell us a little
bit about who are they like how what is
a Gd
how do you become one yes that's an
excellent question so a gde is somebody
that's passionate obviously about how to
technology in our case Google cloud
platform the program here is a way for
them to be actually involved in speaking
to program product managers in
development teams providing feedback and
taking what they learn and eventually
when this hits the market and trying to
help us get the word out when it comes
to you know spreading the news and and
and speaking publicly writing blogs so
number of listeners here will probably
recognize some names as people authoring
blogs and maybe good public speakers as
well yeah they're all definitely very
active in the in the open community but
I've heard that they also get like
privileged access to Google information
like they have an NDA or something right
right right and and then I'll get to the
question about how you become one
because that's an interesting one yes
there are under NDA and that is how we
can have some very interesting
conversations about the things that is
on the product managers mind like the
plans that they have and try to validate
those or amend them is if possible and
and get those people into early access
program maybe in the in a more
systematic way then it would be if
you're completely outside that that
program and and how do you become one
well you really need to be pretty
technical we're really looking for
people that are able to pretty much be
developer advocates right we just don't
hire them we have this relationship
where we share a lot of stuff under NDA
we bring them to Mountain View once a
year for a summit that's what's
happening this year and this week and in
fact and and and we hope that in return
we'll will get feedback from them and
I'm from the sessions today there
definitely is feedback oh yeah some of
it is really good and and anammox hat
and I'm really happy about the way it's
going and and they're a part of the job
is to help us get the word out there so
it's very similar to a number of other
programs this one needs to be very
technical and we're looking for
influencers and
you know we're always looking for people
around the world to help us spread the
news yeah I was I was in the room a
couple of minutes ago before and I was
listening to one of the talks and I
gotta say they're a really tough
audience when a product manager would be
like well we think about this and isn't
that rather than be like oh that is nice
someone could be like what about this
other one okay exactly tough audience
and that's what we're looking we have an
opinion yeah they have an opinion and
that that's worried that's why they're
GTEs we expect the feedback we're not
looking for people that will just rehash
whatever the party line is we're looking
for people that make the messaging
whatever it is there's and and we'll
amend it and we'll you know give it
their full potential given what they got
out of it that is awesome thank you so
much for taking the time to tell us
about today today you bet now that we
have a great idea of what GDS are and
what they do why don't we go talk to
some so we're very happy to have Lin
Lang get today hello how are you doing
hey I'm doing great and you're one of
the CDs that I know the mosque is your
you write a lot about Windows and so
many other crazy things why don't you
tell us a little bit what what do you do
what do I do I'm an independent cloud
and big data architect most recently
I've been working as lead on an IOT
project on your competitors cloud but I
am actually starting to do some work now
back on your cloud in a really
interesting vertical and that vertical
is scaling cancer genomics nice what
tell us a little bit more about that
yeah yeah sure well because I'm
independent I can pretty much pick my
projects and so unfortunately a friend
of mine got cancer and I was startled to
see the lack of access to personalized
treatments and so I started to do some
research and I have a teenage daughter
who had the good fortune to attend
Stanford this summer and study cancer
biology so she had some information for
me as well and in looking at the state
of research biology I found that there
was an opportunity to help educate the
researchers about using various vendors
clouds to scale so as I started to look
into this I saw that you guys and here
at Google actually
have a genomics API in alpha and being a
gde I have access to some of these alpha
you know things that you guys have so I
got access to it and started working
with it
and started learning biology and here we
go
that sounds awesome that's really
amazing cool so can you share some of
the results of it like what your how how
was your experience how is it working
with an alpha project so alpha project I
mean I build software to write so alpha
projects are alpha projects but the
genomics API really was very much a
Minimum Viable so it was variant
processing so you know you input the
data and then you magically get out of
variant so what the heck is a variant
right for those of us who don't work in
biology so I'm still working on my
understanding so if you are a biologist
listening you know don't cringe but the
idea is that you've got genomic
sequencing input you know so you know te
AGC all that kind of stuff and then you
compare that with a reference genome and
then you find the variations or the
variants which I'm coming to understand
is actually a very small percentage you
know less than 1% but it's those
variants that are critical in
personalized medicine interesting cool
well I also know you've been a GD for a
little while how did you end up becoming
a Gd what got you involved in the
program I did a presentation on App
Engine about 6 years ago
I'm doing all Microsoft audience yeah
that gets you though and now I'm curious
like what is your favorite thing about
being part of the GD program with what's
been great for you so it's been really
cool because you know I've been since
since its inception to see the program
grow you know they were like 10 15
people and at this year's summit there's
300 around 300 people I think yeah so
it's super cool to see you know the
program grow to see new people come into
the community to get to know people
across the world because I'm one thing
about this program it really is a global
program and its really interesting to me
to learn about different areas of the
world travel and work another thing that
I'm doing is I'm starting to do some
work in
a pack region and I'm very excited that
you guys are opening a data center in
Australia me too
yeah so so actually it's the combination
of the two things I applied and got
accepted to speak at a biology
conference on scaling using Google how
to scale genomics in Australia ooh
congratulations I know so I'm doing that
in February next year
what's the name of the conference in
case people want to know it's called
galaxy 2016 so galaxy is an emerging
tool out of the biology research
community it was created at Johns
Hopkins and the idea is to leverage
docker so that you can capture
configuration because another really
interesting problem in this space is
that a lot of the research is not
reproducible because people do it on
their desktop they do it on VM instance
they don't capture all the settings and
so something is simple and some that we
all know as a you know using docker to
capture configuration can't really help
yep very very very interesting I never
thought that the cloud would be so
helpful to such interesting and
important things like cancer so so thank
you so much Liam for your time and have
fun with the rest of the summit and
thanks so much for being a gd8 thank you
so much thanks we are joined again by
another fantastic GD aleni
thank you so much for joining us how you
doing today I'm doing terrific great
really good thank you so much for being
at GD e can you just tell us a little
bit about you and what you do sure I'm a
Java developer and I work with App
Engine since I've been exists and I
absolutely love the two because just
make our life incredibly easy and you
know I hate DevOps and App Engine just
saves my life and yeah and since then I
never stopped and I'm glad if this you
out there and working great nice so are
you are you independent do you work for
a company yeah I used to work with a lot
of companies like Nike calkins Citibank
heard of them yeah kind of like that and
you know you name it in Brazil I'm from
Brazil too so a lot of companies in
Brazil but now I'm a little bit tired of
corporation word and I'm playing with a
few startups
and let's see how it goes excellent I'm
worried about to you located
I'm locating rasili real yep cool and so
as a gde like other communities out
there that you're involved with or
events or any fun stuff about that in
that in that sort of region that people
should know about if they want to be
interested in Google's out of course not
it's specifically for cloud Google cloud
and like forget about App Engine and but
there are a lot of Google events out
there and they're growing a lot and you
know I just went to adapt fast and our
center central Brazil and was like seek
hunt 600 developers was it Belo
Horizonte it was gone yeah yes we're big
and it's growing it's popping up all
over the place yeah so and that's that's
good because this is all new things
happening it wasn't like that before so
it's being like that now cool could you
tell us a little bit about how you
became a DD yes so a lady that I you
know I'm a balloon a fan off she come
yeah she called a lean language she was
the first GD of the program and you know
she basically invented I think so Joe
Kane just got that but no she you know
she was there since the beginning and we
are friends from San Diego I used to
live in San Diego too and and we worked
together there and we play and we teach
kids and we do all you know fun things
over there you used to do and as soon as
she became Gd and it becomes a real
program and it starts growing and she
said okay I have chewing five people and
you know she saw me and bite me and I
jump in right away and I said what an
opportunity right what a real
recognition and and that since then is
making my life easier for my you know my
resume for my my personal marketing and
everything it's incredible so we we
already covered what was your favorite
part of the
which is fine what about what is your
favorite part of being a Gd
I think it's two things that I love the
most one is the GD community that it's
just you know incredible people they all
look like me though I feel like to play
home I feel you know outside of the tak
community the Google community or the GD
coming I feel weird right I'm a nerd and
I'm weird but inside GD I'm totally
myself that is I you know I'm home so I
love that and outside of the being a GD
for the whole word when I say oh do you
work for Google though you know that
makes me look nice I have to you know
like rephrase it no I don't but still
they don't care what we say they think
you know we are yep
a Google thing yeah I think that good
the the the name Google opens some doors
sometimes Ahmed's
so all the doors all doors I want to be
open it's awesome
wonderful um before we finish up are
there anything coming up or any events
or things that people would like to like
the easier you're involved in or you
want to like sort of promote that are
happening in your region the people be
interested in yeah this your field that
fast going on and in to the end of the
month and writes the that first month so
I'm going to a few of them I'm gonna
speak on at Beijing flexible oh nice
yeah and how to reduce cost on the cloud
because cost is being a big thing and
what else and after that I'm gonna
really focus on my startup things and
what are the names of the deficits that
you're going to the first Campinas is
the one I'm gonna speak Oh excellent
well thank you so much for joining us
today we really appreciate you taking
the time thank you for being edgy be
thank you so high with Daniel kookier
where are you from from Brazil Sao Paulo
Brazil nice I was supposed to go there
so it was a little bit about yourself
what
so I run a company a startup in Sao
Paulo it's a music analytics platform we
use big data and music data to help
music professions to expand their
audience and to develop the erroneous
ways what's the name of the company it's
play X play X cool could you tell us a
bit more about how is it that you're a
gde so basically I I use a lot of Google
Cloud I have been using cloud generally
in in my whole life developing some of
software and then and they start up we
needed a lot of computing power to start
the business so it's it's a different
kind of business that you you need a lot
of computing to start so even from
scratch we didn't have had customers but
we needed a lot of cloud computing and
and Google had this program for for
startups on ice so we could get some
some incentives from Google cloud and
then we started to use Google Cloud cool
so what products are you using currently
what is the product that you're using so
we the most we use is compute engine
cool so we we have something around 50
virtual machines running there but we
also use cloud storage for file storage
actually and a little bit of cloud
sequel also not not so much yeah and the
monitoring stack driver and the yeah you
said you're in Sao Paulo and your G da
you involved with any events or any
communities up there stuff like that
yeah I'm I'm also a technical advisor of
the Venture Capital Group in in Sao
Paulo so I helped a lot of companies in
the their portfolios to to understand
the Google technologies so we we have
private events that I help them to to
start with Google
most of them use Amazon as their
platform for now yeah for now so why
don't you tell us what is your favorite
thing about being a GDI Google developer
expert if you were to choose one to be
here with you guys actually and now the
real answer so it's cool to have access
to two primer information so before the
products get launched so we we can plan
and maybe when we know before anyone we
can okay we let's wait because Google
will launch something in the next month
or instead of start trying to tackle
this problem and do a lot of work on
that we can wait and so having
privileged information about that is
cool and also having access to many
other developers other experts it's it's
it's great because we can change
knowledge and this is wonderful
oh and one last question what is your
favorite product or feature of Google
cloud platform one feature that I think
is very interesting is is the
preemptable instances nice so we use a
lot so we could actually and I wrote a
blog post about it could decrease our
cost in 40% after moving part of our
infrastructure to preemptable instances
cool I really and and compared to others
for example compared to spot instances
in in Amazon it's a lot better because
you can spot you have all this complex
seed things that you need to do and and
Prem Tebow is much more predictable so
you know that the the the servers will
go down next 24 hours so you plan for it
and you already know how much you're
gonna pay for that so this is this is
great all right Daniel thank you so much
for joining us and thank you so much for
all the work you do as a GDA we really
appreciate it thanks thanks so I'm happy
to have DVR in the go clapper for
how are you doing today and fine why
don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself
we we kind of know wait da you are from
France but what do you do so I'm the VP
engineering arts fair it's a concert at
tea company company we are about 300
developers I'm doing some cloud stuff
about 88 years right now for now and
that's it go use a little bit more about
your experience of the GD how how long
it's been since he joined the program so
I change the program in 2012 so it's a
long time ago yeah how did you end up
being a DDA yeah so I start to use the
App Engine as a beta tester it was in
2008 and first I was using it for my own
I built on top of App Engine a bit
nandroid up equations it was quite a
success because I've got about 1 million
of download of the applications and I
I find it very easy to use engine and
quite useful so I start to push App
Engine inside my company and then the
story starts cool what language was this
at first I was using pythons and I
switched to Java on now I'm using go
mainly across on Nexus PHP that's sure
nice so whether you tell us a little bit
about your experience with the platform
what what kind of what is your favorite
products oh so you asked me for my
favorite products and yes more feature
feature maybe I have to App Engine I
love a lot of engines because it helps
to to build very scalable application
it's very easy to do that for example I
have built an applications for clients
we want to scale from zero to millions
of people in a few minutes and it's App
Engine can help us to do that yeah and
maybe the second one is bigquery because
for the same reason you can have a query
Zack run
a billion of lines and you have the
result in a few seconds I love that yeah
I gotta say that one of the times I went
to I think was in devoxx Paris I went to
one of your trainings one of your beaker
a trainings it was pretty amazing
I know bigquery and I was impressed well
it sounds like you hit up a number of
events for doing presentations and
training would have been some of your
favorite events that you've been talking
at I don't remember which one was the
best that's what's most memorable then
yeah I love to talk to devoxx for
example also to def fest and to small
event also because it's of course it's
funds to go to a large event with with a
hundred of people but sometimes you have
very nice moment in a small place with
maybe only 30 people there like in Java
user group of our GDG or something like
that
yeah whether you tell us about what is
your favorite part about being a DD
being a Google developer expert what I
love is just to share what I know about
a platform nice just simple and is that
mainly through training and
presentations or do anything else I'm
doing merely presentation on training I
have trained about in France but I think
I'm near 1,000 people training that's
very that is more than me I think that
is very amazing yeah me too I need to
get where I need to get working yeah
that is awesome all right well thank you
so much for joining us today I really
appreciate you taking the time and
thanks so much for being a gde
thanks thank you go hey Krishna thank
you very much for joining today how are
you doing I'm doing good enjoying the DD
summit as always this has been my third
GD summit so far nice excellent um you
wanna tell us a little bit about you
what you do your background okay so I
came into the GD world from actually the
GDG world which is a Google developer
group yep
I'm found out of the Google developer
group in Singapore which I did so in
2009 around June that was just six
months after the first GDG or it was
called
jitta at the time that was created by
Van Riper
so I was managing the group until the
end of last
that is an 2015 and over the span of
five years I did 60 events and I've
given nearly 20 public talks in
Singapore Brunei Taiwan Malaysia I think
virtually over Bangladesh a little bit I
believe in Indonesian as well that's
that's a fairly impressive resume I
assume that means you're based out of
Singapore I moved to the US I had an
opportunity to work on a Google cloud
platform product yep some currently
based in Washington DC what moved you
know I'm very new to us so from this
January I'm living in Washington DC next
and on top of all these impressive
activity you also wrote a book yes I did
write a book thanks for reminding bring
it oh yeah so I wrote the first book on
the Google cloud platform it was called
on building your next big thing on
Google cloud platform that's very very
passionate to me nuts because you know I
got so much support from Googlers like
yourself and also the other product
managers who reviewed each and every
chapter of the book and I believe till
today that is the only comprehensible
that has been written I am looking
forward to have some time to actually
rewrite the book but probably in a
different form not as an entire book
because the pace at which the Google
cloud platform universe is expanding
there is no way I can write one book
cover-to-cover
and it's just going to be you know Bible
very soon right yeah by the time you
finish the book also we have yeah that
is cool it sounds like you've done a
whole bunch of events were there
particular events around the APEC region
that you found were particularly great
like community events or conferences or
anything like that writing you spoke so
much around the area so primarily my to
my talking's we're in the GDG meetups in
Singapore then on the dev fest in Brunei
then there was one event it was some
kind of a cloud conference in Malaysia I
forgot the name that was having a multi
vendors kind of thing and I presented
about the Google cloud platform there
fantastic
cool so you mentioned that you've been
part of the GTE prom for at least three
years this is the third time that you
come to the summit that's right
what is your face
para being a GB okay my favorite part is
the opportunity to test new technologies
and to give direct feedback to the
program managers right our product
managers that's my favorite part of
being a gde
and that's you know that's where we feel
that we are valued so much and we are
the small group of people who are trying
on value by Googlers by the Google as a
company itself where they're trusting us
to know with all these upcoming things
and we can give the feedback and win
many cases out feedback actually product
Isis right I get get absorbed into the
product yeah I really like that at the
end of every single session there's a QA
but it is not really a QA it's just the
audience giving their opinion about
things which is pretty awesome oh yeah
yeah so it's a very open discussion even
today and I enjoyed every single session
where I guess we didn't even have a Q&A
at end of it because we started
interrupting the speed yeah yeah
excellent well Krishna thank you so much
for joining us thank you so much for
being a GDA we really appreciate you
taking the time and thank you for
interviewing me thank you so now we are
joined not by one TD but by two we have
Albert and Vikram hi how are you doing
hello
hello I'm good CDs are better than one
yeah and also I think that the good
story here is that they actually know
each other how do you know each other so
we actually met back in GCP next last
year and since then we have been touched
with each other and he is in Indonesia
and I've been in I'm from Philippines in
touch with like other GDG communities
and cool so it's Google developer
friends that is so cool yes actually it
was quite funny how we met so we we were
standing in line in queue to the cloud
vision booth a moto booth and then so
then the guy said next and I was like
okay who's gonna go first human and the
guys both of you come over and so we
like post together and then we
introduced each other I actually didn't
get his name to get my name we just sort
of like you know we had a picture
together and then my friend a Googler
back in the Philippines um said oh
you're in GCP like meet Vikram you
should meet Vikram and he tagged him to
my profile and then I look
there's like I've met this guy so I
started hunting him around again
TCP next missed connections that's super
cool all right so why don't you both
tell us a little bit about yourselves
and you know so what your backgrounds
are and what you're doing what are you
okay so I'm the CTO and co-founder of
Sims were a branding design web and
mobile development company so we do work
for companies and governments we do a
lot of work maybe I think that brands
who recognize really like the government
of Philippines brand the World Bank and
other clients as well both local and
overseas the Philippines so we have a
team of about 40 people we do a lot of
our work in Google cloud platform
obviously that allows us to really build
and the products for a clients quicker
without having to worry about much of
the DevOps
yeah so I'm a full-stack developer at
Omni we are based out of San Francisco
and we build we are building marketing
like we're easing the marketing needs
for all the analytics performance and
whether it's machine learning on that
and using that to help marketers
simplify their decisions and data
collection cool and I think it's a
little bit about from your personal
experience what is your favorite feature
or product of Google cloud platform
maybe you go first Vikram so one of the
two Pro favorite features favorite
programs I'd really like to know off
strategy for Google so that involves
like one on one end we have App Engine
on the other end we have bigquery so the
both of them when worked working
together they form like the best piece
of like product uses for me because like
I don't have to manage anything and
being in a start-up it's really good for
me because I don't have to worry about
anything like even not nothing on the
database side nothing on the scalability
of the web app that we have very cool
what about you yeah I mean similar here
App Engine um
I mean no ops is really a big thing for
us like if I can press one button
instead of having to configure and do
like 10 buttons I would want the one
button that's the same thing so I like
App Engine very much
I also like I don't know if it's Google
cloud I don't
with officials down here but I really
like firebase real-time database it just
really works really nicely I mean we
tried to we spend hours maybe even day
is like trying to replicate the
functionality ourselves but when you
know firebase it just works yeah I'm not
sure if firebase is technically part of
Google club but it's part of the family
we do love them we let them they will
definitely love them you're both Judy's
why don't you tell us a little bit about
like what you do is a gde and what like
what some of your favorite things to do
as a GD is alright so I do a lot of
talking I like talking more than writing
so I don't have much for blogs or like
maybe even like on a material but I do a
lot of dogs so I go around give talks
encourage students maybe you developers
as well on topics like app engine
firebase even machine learning so we
talked about like tensorflow
we talked about getting started in
tensorflow and just going to tutorials
and making sure that people are getting
to know the latest and they're getting
on board as opposed to just you know
finding out what's there when they start
working or so I really have fun doing
that and mostly just really speaking
around the area cool what about you so I
used to do a lot of public speaking back
while I was in India and since I moved
here moved here my focus has changed
from public speaking to that engagements
and writing more blogs and doing more
hands-on testing and hands-on
development of alpha products which are
already like we have access to so I do
those I get feedbacks back to team or I
go direct engagements with other other
startups which I in the area or startups
which like I have connected through from
India and I could do like hands-on
management and hands-on consultancy
hands-on consistency yeah
so that's really interesting how did you
both end up becoming GTA's what was how
did you end up there so I started on on
Google App Engine or when I would say
Google App Engine what's the only thing
Google cloud that was eight years ago
I've been programming on that since and
then I was just basically like talking
about it advocating for it having my own
workshops didn't even have like Google
support back then like no swags and then
suddenly about like three years after I
started oh my god somebody contacted me
and like my just be kind of dead fish
that was a first step
area I talk about App Engine nobody
really knew about App Engine back then
in our area I said from like that talks
and so I've just continuously be doing
that in fact I didn't even know about
the experts program until I was told
that I was nominated to the program and
like I want you to talk to somebody you
know like you're gonna get an interview
and I'm like oh okay
and so yeah that was pretty interesting
for me I've been pretty much involved
with GDG communities since I was in
school so I ran a GDG for two years
there then I ran a GDG in New Delhi for
two years so I've been pretty much
involved with the GDG community and Gd
in part and I have done multiple events
on Google Cloud and scripts and like web
etc but like I focused myself after
college into more of the cloud stuff and
since then I've been getting more
hands-on on to cloud and since I smoked
here in SF it's been even more hands-on
and then somebody from the team it was
actually racing who discovered me who
would each out to me and he said that
you should apply for this and Alexis at
the GCP next actually last year and
since then I've been here actually math
took my interview so we have to say nice
things about me now go well thank you so
much for taking the time to talk to us
today and thank you for being today's
thank you for having so much yes
rate that was I was gonna say a great
conversation that was a bunch of great
conversations so thanks to all the GDS
that we interviewed also to the ones
that somehow got cut off this episode
otherwise could be like three hours yeah
there are so many gd0 I could have spent
a whole twenty minutes half an hour
three hours talking to high your stuff
so interesting and and and even the ones
that didn't want to talk to us very
interesting anyway I think it's time to
go with the question of the week and the
question of the week today comes as we
said at the beginning comes from slack
and it is about datastore it is okay so
if I delete something from datastore so
to delete something you're gonna use the
delete operation the rebar is a key and
you're gonna say delete this key right
is that strongly consistent or
actually consistent so Francis that's a
really great question because I'm here
many types of things in software
development it depends so basically
within datastore if you're interacting
with a record whether it's delete or get
or put if you're interacting the through
its unique and identified key that is
strongly consistent so if I put
something in datastore and then ask for
it by its key I will get it back
straight away so that is strong ago
sister that is strongly consistent
however generally speaking we'll go into
this in a second when you query for
stuff so you're looking for say like no
mirskiy like numerous records so like
every person who has an age of 23 for
example that is eventually consistent
cool so you have to take so that that
means that in our case if you have a key
like you have a person that is 30 years
old
yep and you delete it and then right
after you ask for give me all the list
of the people are over 23 you might get
that person back because it's eventually
consistent and you might not because
it's eventually can see and now there
are some things in there to make sure it
is strongly consistent there's a thing
called ancestor queries yeah so you can
tie a record essentially to another
record the parent record and when you do
that what that means is when you do a
query you can then do it ancestor query
you're basically saying give me every
person who's over 23 who is attached to
this parent record in that case it will
be consistent the trade-off there though
is in right speed so when you write
things to datastore that are attached to
a single entity you can usually do it
around one per second yeah so that's a
trade-off you have to consider when
designing how are you gonna use and how
you're going to structure your data
within datastore cool I think that that
makes it pretty clear and actually what
I'm gonna do is there's a really really
good explanation of all of this in a
Coursera course it's called building
scalable web applications with App
Engine I need to available for Java and
Python so I'll put a link to that they
explained very very well how how all of
these works and why is it the way it's
done yeah datastore is hugely hugely
powerful but you definitely need to know
how it works there are some constraints
but in exchange you get like crazy
scalability yeah definitely worth it
excellent well Francis thank you again
for another episode are you going
anywhere doing anything just for funking
what do you
- so I again released a new episode of
Joseph funk so go check it out is
youtube.com / c / just for funk with AC
at the end yes and other than that what
am i doing I'm actually enjoying some
holidays so I'll be I'll be going to
China for some holidays and then back to
have an off site with our beautiful team
very nice yeah alright sorry about that
one cool I am NOT going anywhere for I
think the rest of the year crossed
fingers coming to the offside I am
coming to the other side yeah that is
true actually I am coming to the upside
and I will be participating in
Thanksgiving in some way shape or form
which will be interesting eating turkey
yeah well thank you again and I think
that it's been super long time since we
have not given our listeners the ways
they can contact us yes
so why don't we do it I think so how can
they reach us over email
hello DC podcaster come on the website
GCB podcast calm or cloud.google.com
slash podcast they can register on
reddit reddit that come slash are slash
GCV podcast yeah
Google+ plus GZ podcast on slack on
slack there's a channel called podcast
which is part of the group cloud
platform community yeah excellent and I
think the last one I think I'm missing
is on Twitter and Twitter which is just
podcast and also also you're also
forgetting the fact that we're on
YouTube oh yeah yeah so there's a
playlist with all these episodes and
more on the Google cloud channel so go
check it out there's a podcast podcast
playlist or Eve rather than listening to
us on your mobile phone listening to a
podcast application you can also just
watch it there's not much to see it's
just an image but you can listen to us
yeah if your YouTube red subscribers you
can download it our flat storage and
listen to it that way too
this is a very good idea yeah I'm not
about that area good ideas mark yeah
okay open up another idea we had another
episode which is if you want to come on
the podcast but just in a little way if
you want to record a question and email
it in to us oh yes say like as a driver
a drop buckling
or anything like that if you gave us a
good question we'll definitely put in
the podcast and we're actually
considering giving prizes to people that
do this we still don't know what but
mystery termites they're eventually
consistent prices oh I like it there you
go excellent all right Francis thank you
so much for joining me yet another week
thank you Mark and talked to you and to
you all next week see you next week